I uh I used to date a Jewish gal I just
found out she wants to get breast
implants that blew my mind I use the
term breast implants because I don't
like the term fake breasts I like to
turn it doesn't make sense to me because
the breasts are real it's just the
inside that's fake yeah the actual
breasts are still real it's kind of like
the Bible the book is real it's just the
inside it's fake
special book is real it's leather you
know
um
yeah yeah yeah but I gotta figure
something out I'm getting older man I'm
getting older about a year ago I got
paranoided by losing my hair started
taking Propecia could not get an
erection
yeah you remember yeah yeah
ah
this girl I was dating at the time was
like hey you got to get off those pills
I'd rather have a boner than hair which
is nice to hear but that only makes
sense when you're dating somebody it
doesn't work in the beginning
like if I was a bald guy that hurt on a
bar like hey I gotta buy you a drink
she's like I'm good I'm like ah I have a
boner
I know you prefer that to hair
but hey maybe I'll meet a nice gal at
this Festival you know I I can pretend
to have tattoos yeah yeah
ah newly single guy uh back on the scene
went on a date with a girl recently went
pretty well back to her place to take
out a condom she goes whoa whoa whoa
where'd you get that thing
I was like well they were free at the
bar
she was like oh that's gross I was like
well that's where I got you
dates are tough now too because we have
no patience we want everything so quick
we want everything quick we have no
patience we want Tinder fast food
delivery high-speed internet everything
is so quick the only thing we don't want
quick is sex when's that gonna catch up
I was with a girl the other night I
finished kind of early she's like hey
what's going on here I was like well
these are the times we're living in
come on I love the patience for your
vagina to be buffering let's go huh
you're an analog girl in a digital world
sister pick it up